scp-682 versus scp-217  could the clockwork virus finally be  time's up for this unkillable reptile  scp-217 was pumped into scp-682 cell via  a gas pipe at one second scp-682 was  sitting still at seven seconds the gas  was introduced in the containment area  at 21 seconds  scp-682 was coughing as the virus  traveled into its respiratory system for  nine days after this  scp-682 had no visible response to the  virus however at 224 hours 36 minutes  and 24 seconds  scp-682 began to howl with pain the  roaring continued for 35 minutes and 48  seconds at this point the screams began  to quiet until  scp-682 went completely silent and  appeared to be in shock after 36 minutes  682 began to laugh uproariously  apparently having developed an immunity  to the virus